we begin in Sudan's capital Khartoum
where fighting between the Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces is in
its second week that is despite both
sides committing to a ceasefire over the
Eid holiday
these are live pictures of the capital
Khartoum many Sudanese are reporting
that family members are missing the UN
says more than 400 people have been
killed and 3 500 injured but the toll is
believed to be far higher as the
confrontations are preventing people
from retrieving the victim's bodies left
in the streets
we are suffering of lack of food lack of
[Music]
ethnicity lack of water we do not have
electricity for three days now and also
we do not have
access to water since a Saturday
but we are drinking from Wells yeah
situation is still bad foreign
we are suffering a lot due to the water
shortage all the residents here are
suffering from the water issue we also
did not have electricity we got power
back three days ago we were living in
darkness it's not normal first we didn't
have water and then we didn't have power
the box price tickets nearly 50 those
are incredible prices and this regular
bottle of water costs 500 Sudanese
pounds the conditions here are very bad
very serious
well U.S President Joe Biden says that
American Embassy staff and their
families have been evacuated from
Khartoum earlier two ships carrying
staff from Saudi Arabia's Embassy
arrived in Jeddah diplomats from other
members of the gulf Corporation Council
were also on board
France too has begun an operation to
evacuate its citizens the United Kingdom
China Iraq and Jordan say they will all
do the same
meanwhile more than 150 students from
the International University of Africa
in Khartoum have arrived in Al gadaraf
which is in southeast Sudan a government
Source says they're being taken to Addis
Ababa and from there they will be taken
back to their home countries
now one Nigerian student who is still in
Khartoum is pleading for help from her
government saying her situation is dire
since there is no electricity there is
no water I I was having some some little
water left with with me I've been
managing the water I cannot for two days
I can't shower there is no water to
drink there is no food to drink you
cannot go out to the street to buy food
there is no you there is nothing you can
buy and even the cash is not there these
soldiers are roaming about everywhere
and you don't know whether you're going
to be the next because the measles are
you know they're just dropping measles
everywhere
well footage on social media has shown
destruction at a market in Northern
Khartoum buildings were on fire after
intense fighting between the Army and
Rapid support forces
let's go straight to our correspondent
Hibbert Morgan who is in cartoon for us
so here but bring us up to date what is
the situation on the fighting this
morning
well it's supposed to be a third day of
ceasefire here in the capital heartum a
ceasefire that from the very first day
did not hold with fighting uh between
the two sides and civilians caught up in
the middle now in the early hours of
Sunday morning we were able to hear
Heavy Artillery uh strikes in the
northern part of the capital Khartoum
residents say that several districts
have seen or rather heard that Earthly
strikes as well and there's also reports
of fighting going on between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army in
the western part of umdurman that's the
twin city of the capital Khartoum around
the vicinity of the presidential Palace
and the general command that's the scene
of intense fighting between the two
sides there have been the sounds of
airstrikes by Sudanese Army fighter jets
and we were able to hear the sound of
surface-to-air missiles as these rapid
support forces fired back as at those
Jets so it looks like this third day of
ceasefire is not holding despite the
fact that there was a lull in violence
overnight fighting has once again
resumed in the capital between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army I
just want to point out to our viewers
Hippa that we are looking at live
pictures of the city of Khartoum you can
see the smoke there billowing in the
distance clearly demonstrating that
ongoing fighting is going on
and clearly that is a huge worry to a
lot of overseas countries who have
people and staff members who are based
in in Khartoum we've had more
evacuations reported by Foreign
governments in recent hours can you
bring us up to date with the latest on
those foreign governments evacuating
their people
while the United States was able to
evacuate its diplomats those are the
embassy staff and their families only
there are still some other U.S citizens
here in the capital who are still caught
up in the fighting and others who are
staff of the UN Mission now the U.N
mission is trying to evacuate via the
eastern city of Port Sudan they took off
this morning from the capital of inner
Convoy and that's about an 11 hour
Journey from the capital Khartoum to the
city of Port Sudan on a good day without
fighting and without any checkpoints in
the middle but that's not the case right
now so it's likely likely that this
journey will take them longer but
there's still other Nationals who are
also still here in the capital Khartoum
caught up in the fighting their Embassy
says that they're trying to evacuate
them and they're in the process of
coordinating with other Allied countries
to get them to get their citizens out
now the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Army both exchange accusations
of firing at each other as the French
Embassy tried to evacuate their
personnel from the capital the French
Embassy is yet to comment on that and
we're yet to get a statement from them
but it looks like that evacuation is
going slower than what the French
government would want but there's still
other Sudanese as well who are trapped
in this conflict waiting for Allah
infighting for a few hours so that they
too can make their way out of this
conflict okay for now good to talk to
you hibber Morgan giving us that update
in cartoon
now I want to get a little more about
why this violence has kicked off in the
last week and a half in uh Khartoum and
elsewhere in neighboring Khartoum with
Hamid kalafa kalafala who is a
researcher and a policy analyst he joins
us now from Khartoum before we go into
the politics Mr kalafala tell us about
your experience of course you live in
Khartoum what's life been like in the
last sort of week and a half as fighting
is erupted in your city
yeah thank you for having me life has
been uh almost impossible in so many
ways I live very close to the market
that I don't know that you just reported
uh was burned down uh yesterday
and obviously that shows you how uh
these five things are affecting citizens
that they're very close to residential
areas in many cases in the middle of
residential areas
we have been waking up and sleeping
today sounds and noises of jet fighters
bombing shelling and all sorts of heavy
artillery so it's been quite frightening
and ancestful in so many ways but also
there's the other side uh of the
fighting or in terms of uh the
day-to-day needs uh as rewarded
electricity Food Supplies which are all
uh you know in in indeed shortly in
Sydney shortage uh you were just
supported so it has been very difficult
and I think you know the longer this
whole continues people will study even
more in getting food supplies
uh we have been without uh sorry water
for the past uh nine days uh in in our
neighborhood we've had uh a five days in
PCP uh cut then we had it back for a day
then it went out for two days and now
it's back again so it's very difficult
uh to you know get about your daily life
in such a circumstances
now there was this promise of a
ceasefire over the Eid holiday but that
hasn't materialized today would be day
three of that ceasefire if it had indeed
happened why do you think that is why do
you think it's not come through
well both both uh generals of Iraq
support forces
were interviewed Yesterday by different
media uh channels and they both accused
the other party for not uh honoring the
honoring the truth which I think in my
opinion only shows that both of them are
not really committed
towards making uh any any you know
progress uh in this in this situation
they're both not committed and don't
have the will to end this fight yet
because in my opinion one of them was to
uh gain more grounds and have uh you
know more wins before they can uh have
truths or start talking about
negotiation uh uh or peace talks or or
so on so each one of them is trying to
score a little bit uh more uh before
they can slow things down and start
talking about what what are the next
steps are going to be which could be uh
very dangerous
particularly now that uh you know uh
a lot of the international uh uh staffs
and foreign citizens and so on and
getting them evacuated which is great uh
yeah so sorry to interrupt well
I want to know what you think is the end
game here for those two rival generals
what is it that they want
well this is primarily Australian uh
overpower uh so one of them needs to win
so that he could claim power this is how
they see it from most uh ends
and and ultimately they have no problem
in my opinion sacrificing whatever it
comes it it takes like uh compromising
or jeopardizing the security of the
whole uh country uh lives of citizens
citizens
infrastructure being uh still destroyed
and so they have even their own troops
in my opinion I don't think they would
mind uh sacrificing them to uh have
we're in power uh so I think for us they
stand out the ultimate game for them is
to see which one would would win power
but that I think is not without uh
opportunities and and and and openings
to stop them from going there everything
that they do is in coordination and uh
uh in communication with the regional
allies which the International Community
could use uh to deliver this leverage to
uh stop these journalists from
continuing this power struggle okay
really good to get your perspective
perspective Mr Hamid khalafala research
and policy analyst based there in
cartoon stay safe sir
thank you
more than 10 000 people have fled the
fighting in Sudan and crossed into
neighboring chard the world food program
says that number could rise to a hundred
thousand the refugees are in dire need
of Essentials including food clean water
and shelter